Transcription: Willow Bushell
Relecteur: Elisabeth Buffard
[Face à l’épreuve]
[Sophie Belaud]
[Dépasser le handicap invisible]
Bonsoir à tous et merci d’être venu.
Alors je vais commencer cette soirée
par un petit sondage.
Je vais vous demander à tous
de lever la main.
Il faut que je vous vois.
Levez tous la main.
Merci.
Je vais vous poser une question.
Seriez-vous capables
de me citer trois exemples
de handicaps invisibles ?
Si vous n’êtes pas capable,
vous baissez la main.
Attention, je peux vous questionner.
Voilà, je ne suis pas vraiment surprise.
Les gens se sentent peu concernés
par ce problème là.
Et pourtant, l’OMS en 2021 nous a dit
qu’il y avait 1 milliard
de personnes handicapées au monde.
En France,
cela représente une personne sur six.
Ça vous parait beaucoup ?
En fait, 80% des handicaps
sont déclarés invisibles.
Seulement 2% sont en fauteuil.
Dans cette salle ce soir, parmi vous,
statistiquement, il y a à peu près
une vingtaine de personnes handicapées.
Mais vous ne le savez pas.
Alors, il est grand temps que la société
apprenne à appréhender le handicap.
Alors, pourquoi
est-ce que je viens vous voir ce soir,
et vous parler de ce problème ?
C’est parce que moi-même,
j’ai été confronté à ce problème-là,
un petit peu, toute ma vie.
En effet, je suis maman
de deux jeunes filles
qui sont atteintes
du syndrome d’Ehlers-Danlos.
C'est une maladie génétique.
Voilà, c’est une maladie génétique
que je leur ai transmise,
mais je ne le savais pas.
Parce que je suis beaucoup moins attente.
C’est une maladie rare qui touche
le tissu conjonctif et le collagène.
Alors, vous en avez autour des organes,
les muscles, les tendons, la peau.
Ça va causer de fortes douleurs,
des grosses difficultés, de la fatigue,
des risques de blessures,
et tout un tas de situations handicapantes
psychologiquement et socialement parlant.
Alors, c’est lourd à porter
pour des parents.
Mais j’ai été confrontée
à ce problème-là très, très jeune.
Je m’en suis servie pour aider mes filles
dans leur combat.
En effet, quand j’avais seize ans,
ma mère était atteinte
d’une maladie auto-immune,
une maladie invisible,
elle ne le savait pas.
Un jour, on est monté à Paris
voir un grand spécialiste
qui lui a annoncé froidement
qu’il lui restait six mois à vivre.
J’avais seize ans,
ma petite sœur en avait huit.
Je me voyais déjà arrêter mes études
pour pouvoir l'élever.
Et puis elle a continué
à vivre normalement, avec sa bonne humeur.
Elle a rencontré un autre médecin
deux années plus tard.
Elle était toujours là.
Mais celui-ci l’a écoutéé
et il a cherché une solution.
Il s’est rendu compte que l’opération,
dont elle avait besoin
avait déjà été réalisée aux États-Unis,
une fois.
Alors, il l’a opérée.
Il lui a sauvé la vie.
Alors la maladie a continué
à faire son œuvre.
Elle s’est fait opérée
de plusieurs organes, plusieurs fois,
mais elle a toujours gardé son humour.
Je me rappelle à sa dernière opération,
elle a dit au chirurgien :
« Il va quand même falloir me laisser
mon cœur et mes poumons,
parce que
j’en ai vraiment besoin pour vivre. »
Voilà, elle était comme ça,
pleine d’humour et d’amour.
Elle est partie il y a dix mois,
à l’âge de 70 ans.
Et elle qui pensait
ne pas pouvoir élever ses enfants,
a bien vu grandir ses petits-enfants.
Et elle est devenue un modèle pour elles.
Elle leur a transmis leur force.
Ma mère a survécu grâce à son mental
et c’est ce que je voulais transmettre
à mes enfants.
Alors mes filles n’ont pas toujours été
aussi malades,
au primaire, elles avaient simplement
des entorses à répétition.
On nous parlait d’hyperlaxité,
rien d’alarmant.
Puis ma cadette s’est cassé quatre orteils
un jour en jouant avec sa sœur.
Et là, on a commencé
à nous suspecter de maltraitance.
Le harcèlement scolaire
a débuté à l’école.
On leur envoyait des ballons
quand elles étaient en béquilles,
par exemple.
Puis est venu le temps du collège.
Au collège, la maladie s’est dégradée
avec la puberté.
Mon aîné a développé une double scoliose
et elle a dû porter un corset rigide,
jour et nuit.
Elle pouvait l’enlever uniquement
pour manger.
Mais malheureusement,
elle a développé une allergie
à sa propre transpiration.
Elle était couverte de boutons,
vous imaginez, sous du plastique.
C'était assez difficile.
Puis elle a commencé
à avoir des difficultés pour manger.
Sa mâchoire se déboîtait.
On nous a donc dit
qu’il fallait la faire opérer.
Sauf que nous, nous ne le savions pas,
mais dans cette maladie-là,
les opérations sont vraiment
déconseillées.
La douleur est exacerbée
et on a de grosses difficultés
à cicatriser.
Ne le sachant pas,
nous sommes rentrés à l’hôpital.
Et ça a été la pire épreuve de notre vie.
Fallait monter au bloc.
On lui a cassé la mâchoire,
on lui a revissée.
On a profité
pour lui faire des dents de sagesse.
Et quand elle est descendue,
elle était intubée,
elle ne supportait pas la morphine.
Il n'y avait rien qui pouvait la calmer.
Sa bouche était maintenue fermée
et elle n’arrêtait pas de vomir.
La deuxième nuit,
elle ne pouvait pas parler.
Elle m'a écrit sur son ardoise.
« Maman, est ce que je vais mourir ? »
Alors c’est une infirmière un peu plus
à l’écoute que les autres
qui nous a aidés dans cette épreuve,
et on s’en rappelle encore aujourd’hui.
Les suites ont été difficiles.
On est sorti de l’hôpital,
elle a perdu treize kilos
alors qu’elle était déjà très fine.
Elle a dû réapprendre à manger.
On ne peut pas passer devant cet hôpital
sans fondre en larmes.
C’était,
c’est toujours un vrai traumatisme.
Pendant ce temps, ma cadette se battait
avec toutes ces intolérances alimentaires
puisque la paroi
de ses intestins est devenue poreuse.
Sortir avec ses amis, c’est très compliqué
puisqu’elle ne peut pas manger
la même chose.
Et elle a développé
une hypersensibilité au bruit.
On arrive donc au lycée,
avec les crises qui ont débuté en classe.
Alors, ces crises, elles en parlent
comme une espèce de cristallisation
de leurs muscles,
avec une douleur tellement intense
qu’elles ont perdu connaissance.
Et à chaque crise, je devais
aller les chercher à l’infirmerie,
avec le fauteuil roulant
puisqu’elle ne pouvait plus marcher.
Les organes touchés se sont multipliés.
On a eu :
le système reproductif, urinaire,
digestif.
Certains symptômes apparaissent
et d'autres disparaissent.
Et pendant tout ce temps,
nous étions en errance médicale.
On nous a parlé de crise d'épilepsie.
On nous a parlé de crises d’angoisse
puisque évidemment,
nous, parents, mettions beaucoup trop
de pression sur leurs épaules.
On nous a parlé d’une maladie dégénérative
qui allait les mettre
en fauteuil dans l’année.
Mon ainée allait de médecin en médecin,
ça ne faisait que la fatiguer.
On n’avait aucune solution.
Elle a décidé de plus y aller.
Puis j’ai un ami, heureusement,
qui nous a envoyé voir
le spécialiste
du syndrome d’Ehlers-Danlos à Nantes.
Il a enfin posé le diagnostic.
Alors il n'y a pas de traitement
pour cette maladie.
Mais par contre, il y a des solutions
qui les aident aujourd'hui.
Alors elles se sont accrochées.
Elles ont rien lâché.
Ma cadette a été déscolarisée
en terminale.
Elle a donc préparé toute seule
son bac scientifique.
Elle l'a eu avec mention très bien.
Et en parallèle, elle a décidé
de préparer un concours post-bac,
pour intégrer l’école de ses rêves.
Et elle y est parvenue.
Mon aîné a choisi la voie
de la prépa, en deuxième année,
elle a été alitée
pendant trois mois avant ses concours.
Alors évidemment,
elle n’a pas eu ce qu’elle voulait.
Mais au lieu de s’arrêter là,
elle a décidé de recommencer toute seule
une troisième année
et elle a obtenu l’école de ses rêves.
Alors ce n’est pas un hasard
si elles ont atteint leurs objectifs.
Il y a différents paramètres
qui peuvent vous aider.
Et vous pouvez les utiliser
lors d’une longue épreuve.
C'est ce que je vais essayer
de vous expliquer.
Le premier paramètre,
c’est qu’il faut avoir un but dans la vie,
des objectifs à atteindre.
Pour mes filles,
ça a été leur projet professionnel.
Mais ça ne suffit pas,
il ne faut pas se laisser abattre.
Et pour ça, il faut des moments heureux
sur lesquels se raccrocher.
Pour nous,
ça a été les vacances en famille.
Fauteuil ou pas fauteuil, nous partions.
Et au quotidien,
comme elles le disent si bien,
la ronron thérapie.
Ensuite, il faut croire en soi.
Il faut croire en soi,
ne pas se laisser définir par le handicap,
ni laisser personne vous définir
par le handicap.
C’est comme
lorsque vous avez une grosse difficulté,
si vous vous la représentez
comme une montagne à gravir tout droit,
vous allez même pas essayer.
Par contre,
si vous cherchez différentes étapes,
différents chemins,
avec de la persévérance, vous y arrivez.
Et pour garder la tête froide,
il faut pouvoir parler.
L’entourage a un rôle très, très important
s’il n’a pas peur de la maladie
ou du handicap.
Cet entourage peut avoir
un regard extérieur très intéressant :
il doit vous écouter,
mais il est là aussi pour vous dire
que lorsque vous êtes trop fatigué,
il faut faire une pause,
et que ce n’est pas un échec
de remettre le combat au lendemain.
Mais pour cet entourage,
c’est aussi lourd à porter.
Le sentiment d’impuissance
est très difficile à accepter,
car non seulement vous êtes impuissant,
vous ne pouvez rien faire,
mais vous devez pousser
ces personnes malades.
Quand j’ai mes filles allongées
devant moi en train de souffrir,
je suis obligée de leur dire
« Reprends-toi,
tu ne dois pas perdre connaissance. »
parce que sinon, les crises sont
bien plus compliquées à gérer pour elles.
Vous l’avez compris, avoir un entourage,
pour nous, ça a été très important,
un entourage à l’écoute.
Mais aussi il y a des professionnels
qui peuvent vous aider.
Alors, trouver le bon médecin
n’est pas évident
et c’est très très important
dans le cadre du handicap invisible
de poser un nom sur cette maladie.
Poser un nom vous donne de la légitimité.
Ça permet aussi d’arrêter
de douter de soi
pour des choses
que vous ne maîtrisez pas.
Pour cela, le corps médical, scolaire,
professionnel plus tard,
a un rôle très important à jouer.
S’ils sont à l’écoute
et qu’ils agissent en conséquence,
ils peuvent tout changer.
Avoir les bons aménagements
de temps, de matériel
et surtout le bon accompagnement,
leur permet vraiment de tout accomplir.
La responsable handicap de l’école
de mes filles aujourd’hui,
puisqu’elles sont dans la même école,
l’a très bien compris.
Elle leur a permis, par exemple,
de rester à la maison,
de suivre les cours à distance
lorsqu’elles sont incapables
de se déplacer.
Elle leur permet tout simplement
d’évoluer et de s’épanouir
dans leurs études.
Souvent, finalement,
c’est l’administration d’un côté
et l’ignorance des gens de l’autre
qui posent problème.
Du côté administratif,
les processus sont longs et compliqués.
Avoir la reconnaissance du handicap a été
un véritable parcours du combattant,
surtout que la maladie est rare
et qu’elle ne fait pas partie des textes.
Je vous parlais tout à l’heure
de ma cadette qui avait été déscolarisée.
En fait, elle ne supportait pas le masque.
Elle avait trop grosses douleurs.
Leur spécialiste a fait
un certificat médical.
L’École était d’accord, elle avait
un petit coin dans le fond de la classe
et elle ne se mélangeaient pas
avec les autres.
Mais lorsque le médecin scolaire
a eu vent de la situation,
elle m’a téléphoné pour me dire
« Mais madame,
votre fille ne fait pas partie
des cases. »
Donc, ils m’ont renvoyé ma fille
pour toute sa terminale.
Mais même lorsque tout est fait
au niveau des instances,
les gens ont vraiment
un rôle très important.
Car le handicap invisible
est invisible par définition.
Lorsqu’on rencontre une nouvelle personne,
la question qu’on se pose,
c’est  dois-je en parler ? »
Là , il y a deux options :
si on en parle,
les gens souvent prennent la fuite
car la maladie est encore taboue.
Ou simplement prennent pitié.
Et si on n’en parle pas,
ils ne peuvent pas vous comprendre
quand vous êtes vraiment trop fatigué
pour simplement communiquer.
Alors je n’ai pas du tout,
je n’ai pas la solution à tout ça.
La solution doit venir de nous tous.
Il faut que la société garde en tête
qu’une personne sur six est handicapée.
Il ne faut pas juger trop vite
quelqu’un qui n’ose pas en parler.
Si vous entendez quelqu’un qui subit
ce genre de choses,
intégrez la formation.
Essayer de comprendre cette personne.
Ce sont souvent des gens
qui sont très sensibles, très matures,
qui ont un recul sur la vie,
qui en veulent.
Et elles peuvent vous apporter
tout autant que vous à elles
si vous les considérez
comme des personnes normales
qui ont juste besoin
d’un petit coup de pouce.
Moi, aujourd’hui, dans mon école,
quand je fais des entretiens d’admission,
je suis très sensible à tout ça.
J’essaie de voir
s’il y a ce genre de difficultés,
et tout de suite, je leur en parle,
je les mets à l’aise
et on met en place
tout ce dont ils ont besoin.
Ils le savent.
Du coup, ça se passe très, très bien.
Alors si vous n’aurez retenu que ça,
la nécessité d’écouter,
alors j’aurais déjà réussi quelque chose.
Merci à tous.